[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today joh join
us in Irvine California Sean how can we
help you today hi guys how you doing
doing well doing great good good good so
I just had a quick question um so I
currently you know I'm not in I'm not in
debt really that much really just from
school and um a surgery that I had but
that not it doesn't even amount to like
Grand which is totally manageable um the
on the other hand I don't I have about
seven credit cards um with very little
balance if anything they're just my
remedial um uh they're paying for like
Netflix you know like stuff like that on
payment plans every month for those for
that kind of stuff um however it does
amount to over
$100,000 of open Credit Now with that
much trying to impress us Sean CU it's
not working so far no no no it's scary
because I I need to get I need to I'm
gonna buy a house soon why and what was
that
why um because we're our rent is just
going out of control that I'm paying
right now and it's almost amounting to a
new house payment um a mortgage if I
just paid like $1,000 more I'd be in a
mortgage how much do you
make so I make about $90,000 a year okay
and you
married no no okay who's you kept saying
hour hour rent hour
rent oh sorry you kept saying hour rent
is going up who's the hour is there
someone else in the picture oh our
roommate roommates got it how old are
you so I'm 31 Oh I thought you were
younger the way you were talking
okay you're just too you're just too so
no I meant it I meant it in a good way
meant it in a good way Sean um you have
a very young energetic
voice so you're 31 you want to buy a
house for
Sean yeah okay which will somehow save
you
money well yeah because I have like
$70,000 saved up for this why are you
hanging on to debt when you have 170,000
sitting there no I don't um so the ho or
sorry the um the hospital bill is
interest free
so um if I'm not paying interest on it I
figured not to so what do you owe in
medical bills well I want to know from
Sean what are you what are you calling
us for what's your what's your number
one question should you buy a house is
that the number one thing that you want
to know what with lenders like seeing
how much credit cards I've have I have
is there a problem with um that they see
me having so many credit cards do I need
to close some I don't want to close any
because it hurts you know I know it
hurts your credit score um okay but I'm
okay so Sean you called a kind of a
different show just so our advice is
going to be probably opposite of what
you usually hear because we are not fans
of credit cards we're not even fans of a
credit score we're not fans of keeping
around debt we want debt in that entire
game that everyone plays out of your
life 100% forever ever amen and that's
Sean's $90,000 that he makes is all his
there's no game to play he has cash in
the bank that's saved in a high yield
savings account for an emergency fund he
has a good down payment he's funding
retirement and he's doing things that
are good for sha this whole game that
you're playing is normal it's what most
people do but here at Ramsey it is a
completely different mindset to the
point that we would say close all of
your credit cards pay everything off get
a debit card pay for Netflix with a
debit card and your credit score will
lower because it is all mathematically
calculated by debt there's about seven
seven layers of your credit score and it
all has to do with debt so when you stop
going into to debt when you start paying
off debt and eliminating debt that score
inevitably will go down to the point in
about 12 months after paying off all
your debt it will be undetermined it
goes to a place that you can they can't
determine your credit score because you
haven't had debt in over a year so then
you'll do a process called manual
underwriting where they will actually
underwrite you a mortgage but that's
after you're debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund and at least 5%
down for that mortgage because for so
many people the thought is well if I
just had a house because yes like you
said some people their rent is even more
expensive than what a mortgage would be
right I mean it is insane what people
are paying for rent so I totally hear
you but when you own a home it's very
expensive when things go out there's not
a landlord to be there there's not
roommates there to split up the rent
right I mean it becomes a very expensive
process and it's a great thing home
ownership should be part of your
financial picture that's a part of
Building Wealth but we want you to do it
in the right
way so okay so we're so opposite of
everything
so against credit cards yeah right y so
if let's just say I mean I I have a
business of my own and I wanted to
expand and use credit for myself how do
you without credit cards how do you get
expansion and Trust from lenders with
why do you want more credit and more
lenders you just told me you were
frightened by a $100,000 line of credit
well no no no but like let's just say
Okay so let's say I I need to get
something for my my business right some
huge purchase that's G to help me make
money in the in the long run okay save
up and pay cash so move at the speed of
cash if I pay that cash though yes am I
essentially draining my my my savings
and all my um no what's draining your
savings is making payments to 14
different
lenders you're going to spend the money
anyways we're just telling you do it
upfront when you have the money so you
don't make stupid decisions that no risk
and that's the other thing is you add on
so much risk especially in a business we
actually have a business conference
going on right now with small business
owners from all over the country and
it's amazing especially in small
business that people out leverage
themselves and when something doesn't
work the amount of stress that is caused
on that it it never ends up good and so
we teach them to run their business
completely debt free and so even for
this company Sean we have a thousand
team members and we only have business
debit cards we don't have a single dime
of debt on this place it's a $300
million paid for building and we moved
at the speed of cash Dave's been doing
this for 30 years this building just
opened 4 years ago and so it's a slower
pace you're wanting to move very quickly
and there's a lot of podcasts and shows
that will help you do that by leveraging
debt we just happen to swim upstream and
go countercultural yeah and and too Sean
part of this you have to understand is
that is that debt there's a weight that
you carry with debt and everyone does
and now in our culture today it's so
normal that people get used to what they
carry around but there is a Freedom that
is caused when you don't owe anyone
anything and that autonomy is what's
missing in our culture today and that
autonomy of being able to make your own
choices being able to have options
because no one you don't no bank is in
your life there's there's nobody that
you are financially attached to you have
complete autonomy and there's power in
that to be able to use your income to
build wealth on the mathematical
financial side but there's an emotional
spiritual side of money too that a lot
of people don't talk about and there's a
freedom that comes when there is no
payments you're not owed by anyone you
make different decisions in life when
you don't have that
risk H I never really thought about like
that yeah okay I want you to hold in the
line uh Sean because Emily's going to
pick up uh I would love to give you
Total Money Makeover it's the
bestselling book that we have here at
Ramsey written by Dave and it'll walk
you through the seven baby steps uh it's
a quick read very easy and this kind of
it'll give you an overall picture of it
and I hope I hope you're enlightened by
it Sean I love that you called because
uh
back I want to hear your millions of
people build wealth and get control of
their money it's just a totally
different way than the world does it so
yeah I'm glad you found us though I've
personally done manual underwriting Sean
without a credit score after I cut up my
cards and between Rachel and I we have
zero credit cards that's what it amounts
to and our wallets are lighter and our
souls are lighter for it this is the
ramsy show